OK, so let's start here. This is a training video for firefighters in Amsterdam.
好的，我们从这里开始。这是一段为阿姆斯特丹消防员准备的培训视频。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Three firemen in an office, drinking coffee, catching up-- and then, one of them, this big bald guy, gets up to show the others this new helmet that he's just gotten, picks up a box off the floor, and says, what is that? He makes a face. It stinks, too. He smells his fingers. What is that?
三名消防员在办公室里喝咖啡、聊天。然后，其中一个身材高大、秃头的家伙起身向其他人展示他刚拿到的一顶新头盔，从地板上拿起一个盒子，说道：“这是什么？”他露出了嫌恶的表情。而且这东西很臭。他闻了闻自己的手指。那到底是什么？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
It's pee. This conversation understandably turns to speculation on how the pee might have gotten there. "Where'd you find this?" he asks.
是尿。这段对话很自然地转向了推测这些尿液是怎么弄进去的。“你在哪找到这个的？”他问。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
At the depot.
在仓库。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Do you think it was a cat? It was not a cat.
你觉得是猫干的吗？那不是猫干的。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
The rest of the video, which is entitled "The Incident With the Helmet," goes on for a few minutes explaining why it is not a good idea to pee in your colleague's helmet, even if it's a joke. Like, that can make people feel bad, and unwelcome. And the reason the fire department needed a video like this was the firefighters were peeing in their co-workers helmets and their drinks, and had been for years.
视频的其余部分标题为《头盔事件》，花了十几分钟解释为什么在同事的头盔里撒尿不是个好主意，即使只是开玩笑。这会让人们感到难过，感到不被接纳。消防部门之所以需要这样的视频，是因为消防员们确实在同事的头盔和饮料里撒尿，而且这种情况已经持续多年了。
This was a re-enactment of an actual incident. Amsterdam firefighters had a kind of macho, frat house culture. And for women who came to work there, or anybody who wasn't white, it was rough in all kinds of ways-- pranks, bullying, racist jokes, sexist comments. Women described the environment as alienating. One Moroccan-Dutch firefighter said, "What we want is not super special. We just want normal behavior, normal treatment of people."
这是对真实事件的重演。阿姆斯特丹的消防员有一种大男子主义的兄弟会文化。对于来到这里工作的女性或任何非白人来说，这里在各个方面都很糟糕——恶作剧、霸凌、种族歧视笑话、性别歧视言论。女性形容这种环境让人感到疏离。一位摩洛哥裔荷兰消防员说：“我们的要求并不过分，我们只是想要正常的行为和对人的正常对待。”
The bosses had problems with them, too. The firefighters would simply ignore certain orders to change the way they worked. Back in 2011, the mayor of Amsterdam commanded them to do some straightforward things, like perform more home inspections, pass out smoke detectors, switch from 24-hour shifts to 8-hour shifts. A year passed, and another, and another. After five years-- still nothing. They'd pretty much blown off his requests.
老板们对他们也很头疼。消防员们会直接无视某些改变工作方式的指令。早在2011年，阿姆斯特丹市长就要求他们执行一些简单的任务，比如进行更多的家庭检查、分发烟雾探测器、将24小时轮班制改为8小时轮班制。一年过去了，又一年，再一年。五年后——依然什么都没做。他们几乎完全无视了他的要求。
The mayor didn't like to hear no.
市长可不喜欢听到“不”这个答案。
Paul Vughts is a reporter at Amsterdam's biggest newspaper, Het Parool. He's covered the fire department for over 20 years.
保罗·沃格特（Paul Vughts）是阿姆斯特丹最大的报纸《Het Parool》的一名记者。他报道消防部门已经超过20年了。
He put his fist on the table and said, "And now, it's over. And now, I'll send you a strong man. He'll change the fire brigade in the way I want it to change."
他拍着桌子说：“现在，一切都结束了。现在，我会派一个强硬的人过去。他会按我的意愿彻底改变消防队。”
The strong man the mayor brought in was a guy named Leen Schaap. His firefighting experience before this-- nothing. He spent his whole career working at the Amsterdam Police Department. And he wasn't just an outsider-- he was somebody with a reputation for being a real hard ass.
市长请来的这个强硬人物叫林恩·沙普（Leen Schaap）。在此之前，他没有任何消防经验。他的整个职业生涯都在阿姆斯特丹警察局工作。而且他不仅仅是个外来者——他还以作风极其强硬而闻名。
I expected a riot because the way they live in the fire stations, being all day and nights, they're together-- cook together, sleep together-- that makes, in the end, that outsiders don't get in easy. Here in Amsterdam, the fire stations are really like small castles in the neighborhood.
“我预料到会有一场骚乱，因为他们在消防站的生活方式——整天整夜待在一起——一起做饭、一起睡觉，最终导致外人很难进入。在阿姆斯特丹，消防站就像社区里的一个个小城堡。”
There's 19 fire stations all around Amsterdam. There were 750 firefighters-- 500 full-time, 250 volunteer-- a brigade with the same problems as lots of brigades here in the United States. And for sure, not all firehouses are like this. But it's not hard to find examples.
阿姆斯特丹各地有19个消防站。共有750名消防员——500名全职，250名志愿者——这支队伍有着和美国许多消防队同样的问题。当然，并非所有的消防站都这样。但要找到这种例子并不难。
Outside of Chicago, male firefighters broke down their female co-worker's shower door while she was in there, showering. The chief handed her a towel and said, "Relax. It's firehouse fun." In Houston, women say their male co-workers peed on their beds, and when they complained, they were labeled troublemakers. The city could not substantiate those claims, but the Trump Justice Department has stepped in on the women's side. In Miami and New York, black fire department employees found nooses at work. In Michigan, a black firefighter found a banana on the windshield of his truck.
在芝加哥郊外，男性消防员在一名女同事洗澡时撞开了她的淋浴间门。队长递给她一条毛巾，说：“放松点，这只是消防站的乐趣。”在休斯顿，女性称男同事在她们的床上撒尿，当她们投诉时，却被贴上了“麻烦制造者”的标签。市政府无法证实这些指控，但特朗普政府的司法部已经介入，站在了女性这一边。在迈阿密和纽约，黑人消防员工在工作场所发现了绞索。在密歇根州，一名黑人消防员在他的卡车挡风玻璃上发现了一根香蕉。
Amsterdam is one of the rare examples of a city that really decides to take on the "boys club" culture in firehouses. And the firefighters don't lay down. They fight every step of the way. And one thing that's unusual about the guy running this department, Leen Schaap, is that he is shockingly frank about just how messed up his department really is. One of his tactics is to be utterly transparent, and show the public what he learns is happening behind the closed doors of the firehouses. He's also blunt about the pushback he gets.
阿姆斯特丹是极少数决定真正挑战消防站“男孩俱乐部”文化的城市之一。消防员们并没有坐以待毙。他们每一步都在反抗。管理这个部门的林恩·沙普，其不同寻常之处在于，他极其坦率地揭露了这个部门的腐败程度。他的策略之一是保持完全透明，向公众展示他在消防站关起门后发现的一切。对于所受到的阻力，他也直言不讳。
And so, unlike other fire departments and police departments with similar problems, in this case, for once, we see exactly how bad things were, laid bare. And we also see all the resistance when somebody comes in and tries to change it. We see just how hard that is to accomplish. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
因此，与那些有着类似问题但选择沉默的消防和警察部门不同，这一次，我们清楚地看到了情况有多糟糕，一切都被赤裸裸地呈现出来。我们也看到了当有人试图改变这一切时所遭遇的所有阻力。我们看到了实现这一目标有多么困难。这里是《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Today on our show, we have this very unusual look inside a place like this. Reporter Joanna Kakissis has been digging into this for months. That'll be Act One of today's show. And this is such an embattled department that the only way Joanna could get most of the firefighters to talk to her was to change their names and replace their voices. So you're going to be hearing a bunch of that in what's about to follow. Basically, only Leen Schaap and one of his main opponents let us use their voices. Our producer, Miki Meek, reported this with Joanna. You'll hear Miki's voice in there, now and then, asking questions. Here's Joanna.
在今天的节目中，我们将一窥这种不寻常的地方。记者乔安娜·卡基西斯（Joanna Kakissis）几个月来一直在深入调查此事。这将是今天节目的第一部分。这是一个充满冲突的部门，乔安娜能让大多数消防员跟她交谈的唯一方式，就是改变他们的名字并替换他们的声音。所以接下来的内容里你会听到很多这样的处理。基本上，只有林恩·沙普和他的一名主要反对者允许我们使用他们的原声。我们的制片人米基·米克（Miki Meek）和乔安娜一起报道了这件事。你会不时听到米基提问的声音。下面是乔安娜。
To take on a bunch of tough guys, the mayor hired someone who was used to being the toughest guy in the room. Leen Schaap climbed to the upper ranks of the Amsterdam Police Department by speaking his mind, and not caring who didn't like it. He got things done by moving quickly and aggressively. He ran the riot squad. He was known in town for forcing out anarchists squatting in a full city block of abandoned homes. Amsterdam is a progressive city, and sympathy was with the squatters. Lots of people hated Leen for what he did. They threw paint bombs at him.
为了对付那群强硬的家伙，市长聘请了一个习惯于成为房间里最强硬角色的人。林恩·沙普靠着敢言和不在乎谁不高兴，一步步爬到了阿姆斯特丹警察局的高层。他通过迅速而激进的行动来完成工作。他曾负责指挥防暴警察。他在城里以强行驱逐占据整片废弃房屋的无政府主义者而闻名。阿姆斯特丹是一个进步城市，当时人们同情那些占屋者。很多人因为他的所作所为而厌恶他。他们甚至向他投掷油漆弹。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Only cowardly leaders don't show up.
只有懦弱的领导者才不会现身。
My interviews with him are filled with these kind of tough guy cliches.
我对他的采访充斥着这种强硬派的陈词滥调。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
This is a battle, and one of us is going to win it. And it's not going to be you.
这是一场战斗，我们之中必有一个会赢。而那个人绝不会是你。
Sometimes, it was hard to keep a straight face.
有时，我很难忍住不笑。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
I'm in the fire department, so I'm not really worried about getting burned.
我在消防部门工作，所以我真的不怕被烧伤。
OK. You're tough. You're tough.
好吧，你很强硬。你真的很强硬。
Leen smiled. He knows when he's laying it on thick. He's intense, with reddish-brown hair and blue eyes that look incredibly icy if you've pissed him off. His first week on the job, there's a welcome lunch for him. Firefighters don't show up. Then, he gets an anonymous letter telling him not to enter any fire stations. He goes anyway, and he notices right away there's nowhere for him to park. The fire station's parking spaces are filled with recreational vehicles.
林恩笑了。他知道自己什么时候在装腔作势。他性格强烈，有着红褐色的头发和蓝色的眼睛，如果你惹恼了他，那些眼睛看起来会冷若冰霜。他入职的第一周，有个欢迎午餐。消防员们都没出席。然后，他收到一封匿名信，叫他不要进入任何消防站。他还是去了，并且立刻注意到他没地方停车。消防站的停车位全被房车占满了。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Boats with caravans, with camper vans-- because basically, the firefighters were using this area around the firehouse as their private space, saying, we're here 24 hours. This is kind of our house. This is our place.
“船只、大篷车、露营车——因为基本上，消防员们把消防站周围的地方当成了他们的私人空间，说：‘我们在这待24小时。这算是我们的房子。这是我们的地盘。’”
Leen gave firefighters their first order. He said, get all your personal stuff out of here.
林恩给消防员们下了第一道命令。他说：“把你们所有的个人物品都搬走。”
Then, they said, you don't run the show. You are not the one who decides this.
然后，他们说：“你说了不算。你不是那个做决定的人。”
He actually said, "You don't run this."
他实际上说的是：“你说了不算。”
"You don't run this. What's your problem?" That's what I said. "What's your problem?"
“你说了不算。你有什么毛病？”我就是这么说的。“你到底有什么毛病？”
And kind of belittling-- "why are you getting so worked up about this little boat we have?"
而且带着一种贬低人的态度——“为了我们那条小船，你至于这么激动吗？”
And what was your response to that?
那你当时的反应是什么？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
I told them, you have to get these boats and the camper vans out of here. If not, I'm going to hire somebody to take all that stuff away. And they were like, oh, go ahead. And I took a step forward, and stood my ground. You know, I threatened to take a police crane and lift it out of there.
我告诉他们：“你们必须把这些船和露营车搬走。如果不搬，我就雇人把这些东西全部弄走。”他们就像在说：“哦，那你试试看。”我向前迈了一步，立场坚定。你知道，我威胁要用警用吊车把它们吊走。
Firefighters were furious, and thought Leen was acting too much like an uptight cop. But everyone complied. They got rid of their boats and campers. Except for one guy, who ignored Leen and defiantly brought a boat right back-- the only boat in the parking lot. Leen put him on probation and moved him to another firehouse. It was one of his first disciplinary actions. The guy retaliated by not coming to work, and taking the department to court.
消防员们非常愤怒，认为林恩表现得太像一个死板的警察了。但每个人都照做了。他们处理掉了所有的船只和房车。除了一个人，他无视林恩，挑衅地把船又带了回来——那是停车场里唯一的一条船。林恩对他进行了留职察看，并将他调到了另一个消防站。这是他最初的纪律处分行动之一。那个人通过旷工进行报复，并将部门告上了法庭。
Leen was figuring things out pretty fast. He estimated there were about 50 of these guys in the entire department-- guys who joined the brigade decades ago, and now ran their fire stations. They kept tabs on their bosses through a private Whatsapp channel. Some firefighters called them "The Brotherhood." Leen always called them--
林恩很快就摸清了情况。他估计整个部门里大约有50个这样的家伙——几十年前加入消防队，现在掌控着消防站的人。他们通过一个私人的WhatsApp频道监控着他们的老板。一些消防员称他们为“兄弟会”。林恩总是称他们为——
The angry white men. We still have them.
愤怒的白人男性。我们仍然有他们。
Angry white men, he says, who are against any change that would force them out of their golden cages. He knew guys exactly like this in his police department days.
他说，这些愤怒的白人男性反对任何会迫使他们离开“黄金笼子”的改变。他在警察局工作时就见过完全一样的人。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
These are tough guys, some born and raised in Amsterdam, or in the streets. They're built like a refrigerator. They have lots of tattoos. They have a big mouth. They're not so much super smart, but they're cunning. And if you try to approach them with too much nuance, then you're not going to make it, because they know how to play you.
这些人都是硬汉，有的出生并在阿姆斯特丹长大，或者在街头混迹。他们长得像个冰箱。他们有很多纹身。他们嘴巴很大。他们算不上超级聪明，但很狡猾。如果你试图用太多的细微差别去接触他们，那你就不会成功，因为他们知道怎么操纵你。
And then, a few months into his job, Moroccan-Dutch firefighters on the force started coming to him about a particular guy, one of The Brotherhood, who called them "cancer Moroccans." In Dutch, this is a racial slur. When I asked for an English equivalent, someone told me "cancer Moroccan" is like saying "fucking Moroccan scum."
入职几个月后，摩洛哥裔荷兰消防员开始向他举报一个特定的人，他是“兄弟会”的一员，他称他们为“癌症摩洛哥人”。在荷兰语中，这是一种种族歧视称呼。当我询问其英语对应词时，有人告诉我，“癌症摩洛哥人”就像是在说“该死的摩洛哥渣滓”。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
And also, when he was supposed to put out fires in Amsterdam-West, where there's a lot of Muslims living, he would say that he had to go to the caliphate.
而且，当他应该去阿姆斯特丹西区（那里住着很多穆斯林）灭火时，他会说他得去“哈里发国”。
This guy had a long list of charges against him. He walked around in a Nazi jacket, he threatened to nail a crucifix to the shower door of a Muslim firefighter, and he refused to go to a fire drill at a mosque. Again, Leen--
这家伙有一长串的指控。他穿着纳粹夹克走来走去，威胁要将十字架钉在一名穆斯林消防员的淋浴间门上，并拒绝参加在清真寺举行的消防演习。对此，林恩再次表示——
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
This is really wrong. What if there's a fire in a mosque? Will he do his job? Will he save the people if he doesn't want to go in there now, for the practice? And as a first responder in this multicultural city, you can't say that you don't want to go somewhere because of religion.
这真的很严重。如果清真寺发生火灾怎么办？他会履行职责吗？如果他现在连演习都不愿意进去，他会救里面的人吗？作为这个多元文化城市的急救人员，你不能因为宗教原因就说你不想去某个地方。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
So when I heard about this case, I thought, I have to do something about this. I can't lead this life.
所以当我听说这个案件时，我想：“我必须对此做点什么。我不能过这样的生活。”
Leen fired him. It was the first time racism had been cited as a reason to fire someone from the Amsterdam Fire Department. So he'd gotten rid of the boats, he'd fired a guy for racism-- progress. But The Brotherhood started a petition for the firefighter to get his job back.
林恩解雇了他。这是阿姆斯特丹消防局第一次以种族歧视为由解雇员工。所以他清理了那些船只，解雇了一个种族歧视者——这是进步。但“兄弟会”发起了一份请愿书，要求让那名消防员复职。
How did you feel about that?
你对此有什么感觉？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
It really opened my eyes. Instead of uniting around the people who were discriminated against, they united against the person who was discriminating, and they formed a block around him.
这真的让我大开眼界。他们没有团结在被歧视的人周围，而是团结在歧视者周围，并围绕他形成了一个团体。
The problem ran so much deeper than Leen thought. Why wouldn't they want to stick up for the guy getting harassed? For Leen, it was obvious. He instinctively sided with the firefighter getting picked on, and he didn't understand anyone who didn't. That empathy for the outsider-- it made Leen an unusual commander. So he started investigating to figure out just how bad things were.
问题比林恩想象的要深得多。为什么他们不想支持那个受骚扰的人呢？对林恩来说，这很明显。他本能地站在被欺负的消防员一边，他不理解那些不这样做的人。这种对局外人的同情，使林恩成为了一名不同寻常的指挥官。于是他开始调查，以弄清楚情况到底有多糟糕。
The numbers were not encouraging. When Leen started, there were only five female firefighters on the entire full-time force of 500. The fire department is not allowed to record race, but he estimates that only around 10% of the force were people of color. These numbers didn't reflect the city at all. At least a third of Amsterdam's population is non-white.
数据并不乐观。林恩刚上任时，500名全职人员中只有5名女性消防员。消防局不允许记录种族，但他估计有色人种只占队伍的10%左右。这些数字根本无法反映这座城市的情况。阿姆斯特丹至少三分之一的人口是非白人。
Leen visited the fire stations, and talked to firefighters over coffee at the long lunch tables there. And he learned that lots of them liked the changes he was bringing in. He had a silent band of support. He asked people about their experiences in the department, and to his surprise, people opened up to him. Through their stories, he started to get a sense of what it was like to be a person of color or a woman in his fire department.
林恩走访了消防站，在长长的午餐桌旁与消防员们喝咖啡谈心。他了解到很多人喜欢他带来的改变。他有一群沉默的支持者。他询问人们在部门的经历，令他惊讶的是，人们对他敞开了心扉。通过他们的故事，他开始了解到作为有色人种或女性在消防部门是什么感觉。
Moroccan and Surinamese-Dutch firefighters said they were called rats and monkeys. The Brotherhood told some they didn't belong-- that firefighters should be Dutch, and white. One Muslim firefighter I'm calling Ali told me that over time, he learned to go along with the racial slurs. So when his co-workers called him "bin Laden," he acted like he wasn't upset.
摩洛哥裔和苏里南裔荷兰消防员说他们被叫作老鼠和猴子。“兄弟会”告诉一些人，他们不属于这里——消防员应该是荷兰人，是白人。一位我称之为阿里（Ali）的穆斯林消防员告诉我，随着时间的推移，他学会了顺应这些种族歧视的称呼。所以当同事叫他“本·拉登”时，他表现得并不在意。
You have to ignore it. If they find out that you don't like it, they'll keep on coming back, and back, and back.
你必须无视它。如果他们发现你不喜欢，他们就会不断地回来找茬，一次又一次。
Have you ever reported discrimination in the past?
你以前举报过歧视吗？
It wasn't possible to do that. Nobody does that. You could report whatever you want, but nothing was going to happen. In the worst of cases, when it really got out of hand, what you would just do is shake hands on it and get it over. The one accused-- he'll just say, come on, man. It was a joke. And nothing's going to happen.
那是没可能的。没人会那么做。你可以举报任何你想举报的东西，但什么都不会发生。在最坏的情况下，当事情真正失控时，你能做的只是握手言和，把它翻篇。被指控的人只会说：“别这样，老兄。那只是个玩笑。”然后什么都不会发生。
Leen hired a consultant to help him reach out to women who'd quit the department. They felt like they never belonged. They said harassment and belittlement happened every hour of the day. One woman said men in her station asked her to leave the room so they could comment on her ass. Men told women to sit in the windows of the firehouse as if they were prostitutes in the red light district. During job interviews, women were asked how they do their jobs on their periods.
林恩聘请了一位顾问来帮助他接触那些已经辞职的女性。她们感觉自己从不属于这里。她们说骚扰和贬低每时每刻都在发生。一名女性说，她所在站点的男同事要求她离开房间，以便他们可以评论她的臀部。男人们告诉女性坐在消防站的窗台上，就像红灯区的妓女一样。在求职面试中，女性被问到她们在生理期时如何工作。
One of the few female officers in the Amsterdam Fire Department is a woman I'm calling Judy. The guys respected her. She was strong, physically, and she was tough-- had no problem standing up to these guys. But even she felt like she was constantly being tested, like when a firefighter under her command purposely opened his towel in front of her. When she suggested that her boss has not put women into fire stations alone, but with other women, one of her superiors called her a "highly educated moaning female."
阿姆斯特丹消防局为数不多的女性军官之一是一位我称之为朱迪（Judy）的女性。男人们尊重她。她在身体上很强壮，也很坚韧——面对这些人时毫无退缩。但即便如此，她也觉得自己在不断受到考验，比如当她手下的一名消防员故意在她面前解开毛巾时。当她建议上司不要让女性独自待在消防站，而是和其他女性在一起时，她的一位上司称她为“受过高等教育的抱怨女”。
One night, she was doing her rounds, checking in on everyone, and stopped by the canteen.
一天晚上，她去巡视查看大家的情况，顺便路过食堂。
I was saying good night to everybody. And then, they were sitting and watching porn.
我当时正在和每个人说晚安。然后，他们正坐在一起看色情片。
Didn't you say something then?
你当时没说什么吗？
No. So I didn't say anything about that.
没有。所以我对此什么也没说。
Porn was a regular thing in the common areas of lots of the stations.
色情片在许多站点的公共区域是常态。
I don't know why I didn't say anything. I didn't feel comfortable to say it, probably. It's also me being influenced by The Brotherhood, I think. Because saying something-- it's always uncomfortable to say that. So yeah, I have to admit that I've avoided it, too.
我不知道为什么我没说什么。我可能觉得说出来不舒服。我想这也受到了“兄弟会”的影响。因为说出来——这总是让人不舒服。所以，是的，我得承认，我也回避了它。
Everyone's grip on what was normal was out of whack. Judy remembers a woman at a fire station who had this particular bedtime ritual.
每个人对什么是“正常”的认知都出现了偏差。朱迪记得消防站里的一名女性有这样一种特殊的就寝仪式。
So she would go to bed, and somebody would come to tuck her in.
她会上床睡觉，然后有人会过来帮她掖被子。
Wait. They tucked her into bed at night?
等等。他们晚上会帮她掖被子？
What exactly do you mean?
你具体指什么？
Oh, tucking in-- it was like when you put your little one to sleep, and you pull your blankets tight around the person. So the guy who would do that said, I'm going to tuck her in. And I felt uncomfortable about that for her. I mean, it was her choice. But I would never do that, because it makes a certain situation that I think you should avoid.
哦，掖被子——就像你哄小孩睡觉时，把毯子紧紧地盖在人身上。那个做这件事的家伙说：“我要去帮她掖被子。”我为她感到不舒服。我是说，这是她的选择。但我永远不会那么做，因为它会造成某种我认为应该避免的情况。
She was fine with it? She didn't mind this happening?
她对此没意见吗？她不介意发生这种事吗？
Well, actually, I don't know. I can't remember ever talking to her about that.
嗯，事实上，我不知道。我不记得曾经和她谈过这件事。
Why?
为什么？
Yeah. That's a good question. Maybe I might be putting her more in danger. Or I might not be helping her. Or maybe I was telling myself, well, maybe it's her choice, and she likes it or something. But yeah, I don't know.
是的。那是个好问题。也许我可能会让她处于更危险的境地。或者我可能没在帮她。或者也许我是在告诉自己：“好吧，也许这是她的选择，她喜欢这样。”但我不知道。
Hearing all these stories, Leen realized he had to spell things out-- what is normal behavior in a workplace. He wrote a manifesto on how to behave like a professional firefighter and sent it out to everyone. It begins, "All of us are going to act normal."
听了所有这些故事，林恩意识到他必须明确指出什么是工作场所的“正常行为”。他写了一份关于如何表现得像个专业消防员的宣言，并发送给了所有人。开头写着：“我们所有人都要表现得正常。”
"Normal" meant, we don't yell at each other. We don't steal coffee from the firehouses. We don't make offensive comments on social media. We always wear our uniforms. We don't store our personal tanning beds in the women's dormitories if we're men. If you break the rules, you'll be punished. And if you no longer know what "normal" is, please find out.
“正常”意味着：我们不互相大喊大叫。我们不从消防站偷咖啡。我们不在社交媒体上发表攻击性言论。我们始终穿着制服。如果是男人的话，我们不在女性宿舍存放个人的晒黑床。如果你违反规则，你将受到惩罚。如果你不再知道什么是“正常”，请去弄清楚。
One of the biggest ways firefighting is not like a normal job-- firefighters work 24-hour shifts. So everyone lives together. They work out, shop for groceries, cook, watch TV, play soccer, sleep. Professional boundaries get blurry. Leen wanted to push the department to 8-hour shifts. It would make fire stations more like a workplace, and less like a private club.
消防工作与普通工作最大的不同之一是——消防员实行24小时轮班制。所以大家生活在一起。他们一起锻炼、采购杂货、做饭、看电视、踢足球、睡觉。专业的边界变得模糊。林恩想推动该部门实施8小时轮班制。这会让消防站更像一个工作场所，而不是一个私人俱乐部。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
I think the fire department-- many of the firefighters will fight almost literally to the death to defend this 24-hour shift.
我认为消防部门——许多消防员几乎会拼命捍卫这种24小时轮班制。
Firefighters liked being together for 24 hours, and hanging out, and then getting a couple days off to spend with their families, or hold down second jobs. And The Brotherhood argued that bonding in the fire station is essential. The pushback was so strong that Leen managed to open just one firehouse on 8-hour shifts as an experiment. The Brotherhood pressured firefighters not to transfer there.
消防员们喜欢24小时待在一起，消磨时光，然后休息几天与家人共度或从事第二职业。“兄弟会”则认为在消防站培养感情至关重要。阻力非常大，以至于林恩只设法在一个消防站尝试了8小时轮班制实验。兄弟会向消防员施压，要求他们不要调到那里。
The guys in The Brotherhood are afraid to talk to reporters. Everyone I reached out to was worried he'd lose his job. But I did get four of them to speak to me on condition that I not use their names. I'll call this one Jan. He did let me use his real voice.
“兄弟会”里的那些家伙害怕接受记者采访。我联系过的每个人都担心会丢掉工作。但我确实让其中四个人同意在我不使用他们名字的条件下跟我谈话。我就叫这一个“扬（Jan）”。他确实让我用了他的真实声音。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
He said the problem in the department wasn't them. It was Leen. And tucking women into bed-- he said it wasn't sexist.
他说部门的问题不在于他们，而在于林恩。至于帮女性掖被子——他说这并不涉及性别歧视。
I can only confirm that they did it to me, as well. And I didn't feel embarrassed about it at that moment. But--
我只能证实他们也对我这样做过。当时我并没有感到尴尬。但是——
The women would tuck you into bed? Is that what--
女性会帮你掖被子吗？这就是你所说的——
No, the men.
不，是男人们。
The men would tuck you into bed?
男人们帮你掖被子？
Yeah, come on. Yeah. There are jokes sometimes, you know? I also went to bed, and I stepped in my bed. And somebody else came from the shower, and he was already, before me, in my bed. So these kind of things happen.
是的，得了吧。是的。有时候会开玩笑，你知道吗？我也上床睡觉，当我躺下时，另一个人刚洗完澡，他比我先钻进我的被窝。所以这些事情会发生。
But if you're a woman, and somebody is tucking you into bed, it's a different experience. And it's--
但如果你是一名女性，有人帮你掖被子，那体验就不同了。而且它——
Tucking is not something that they want to shock you, or they want to embarrass you, or they--
掖被子并不是为了让你感到震惊，或者让他们想让你难堪，或者他们——
Yeah. But I guess what I'm saying is, OK, there are people who are minorities and who are women. They're just too afraid to speak out to you, because they're afraid of repercussions.
是的。但我猜我想说的是，好吧，有些人是少数群体，有些人是女性。她们只是太害怕跟你说实话了，因为害怕报复。
Listen. It's so stupid if I say all the time "it doesn't happen," or "that doesn't happen." It probably happened with one female employee. And probably one female employee left, also. Do you have to say, then, OK, this is a sexist company, or all the females are bullied, or all the Arabic people are bullied? I don't think so.
听着。如果我一直说“那没有发生”或者“那是不存在的”，那太蠢了。它可能确实发生过在某位女性员工身上。也可能确实有一位女性员工因此离开了。那你就非得说“这是一个性别歧视的公司”，或者“所有女性都受到霸凌”，或者“所有阿拉伯人都受到霸凌”吗？我不这么认为。
I asked him about the firefighter Leen fired-- the one who called the Muslim neighborhood in Amsterdam "the caliphate," and used racial slurs on his Moroccan-Dutch co-workers.
我问他关于那名被林恩解雇的消防员的情况——就是那个把阿姆斯特丹的穆斯林社区称为“哈里发国”，并对摩洛哥裔荷兰同事使用种族歧视称呼的家伙。
He's not a racist. That's for 100%.
我可以百分之百肯定他不是种族主义者。
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
To me, it is an incident-- still an incident in a big company. Don't make it bigger than it is. I'm 29 years with my wife, you know? If I focus on all the bad things that I said about her then, we would never get married.
对我来说，这只是一个意外——一个大公司里依然会发生的意外。别把它夸大。我和我妻子在一起29年了，你知道吗？如果我盯着那期间我说过的所有坏话看，我们根本就不会结婚。
You don't think they should have fired him earlier?
你不觉得他们应该早点解雇他吗？
No, no, no, no. No. You don't have to fire him at all. As long as he's not running around naked in his roller skates, he's OK with me.
不，不，不，不。不。你根本不需要解雇他。只要他不光着身子踩着旱冰鞋到处跑，我就觉得他没问题。
You think he can use a term like "cancer Moroccan"-- and you're not a racist?
你认为他可以使用“癌症摩洛哥人”这样的词，同时还不是种族主义者？
It's not OK. But in the heat of the discussion, you say things that are not OK, that you are not allowed to say. And the opposite party will do the same, probably. Yeah. And who is right and who is wrong-- I don't judge that. I was not there. But one thing is for sure-- I know he's not a racist.
这确实不对。但在争论激烈的时候，你会说出一些不对的话，一些你不被允许说的话。对方可能也会做同样的事。是的。谁对谁错——我不予评价。我当时不在场。但有一点是肯定的——我知道他不是种族主义者。
How much do you think that the force should adapt to new firefighters?
你认为队伍应该在多大程度上适应新消防员？
The thing is-- when we have the feeling that we are forced to change, then it's going to be-- that's, in my opinion, the wrong way. So if you want to change, the trick is not to force it, and do it in a very clever way, that you--
问题是——当我们感觉到被强迫去改变时，那将会是——在我看来，那是错误的方式。所以如果你想改变，诀窍不是强迫它，而是用一种非常聪明的方式，让你——
In a very what way?
用什么方式？
In a clever way, that you change without noticing. That would be the perfect way. And this is not happening right now.
用一种聪明的方式，让你在不经意间改变。那将是完美的方式。而现在并没有发生这种情况。
This is what Leen says he was up against-- a group of men for whom "normal" meant keeping things exactly the way they'd always been.
这就是林恩所说的他所面临的对手——一群男人，对他们来说，“正常”意味着一切保持原样。
I was just wondering-- doesn't a boss have the right to impose boundaries on workplaces?
我只是想问——老板难道没有权利在工作场所强加边界吗？
We are not in this business for him. It's not a job. It's a way of life, worldwide. So let's make this very clear-- for us, it is not a job. It's a way of life.
我们从事这行不是为了他。这不是一份工作。这是一种生活方式，全世界都是如此。所以，让我们明确一点——对我们来说，这不是一份工作。这是一种生活方式。
Leen's approach to making big institutional change is based on a progressive fairly new management theory, designed to curb lawless organizations. It's essentially-- draw hard boundaries. Make no concessions. Be consistent, unrelenting. And in 10 to 15 years, maybe there'll be a real shift. It's arduous. The beginning is the hardest part.
林恩进行大规模体制改革的方法基于一种进步且相当新的管理理论，旨在遏制无法无天的组织。本质上就是——划定硬性界限。绝不妥协。保持一致，毫不留情。10到15年后，也许会发生真正的转变。这很艰巨。开始是最难的部分。
This approach made a lot of sense to Leen because of his experience on the Amsterdam Police Force. He helped clean up and reform the department. As a rookie cop, he'd seen the problems firsthand. He started in a corrupt precinct, the red light district in the 1980s. He says cops stole, sold drugs, were excessively violent. Changing that meant rigorously enforcing rules, writing up bad cops, disciplining them, firing them. Leen says it took about 10 years for the rules to be accepted as normal. But this confrontational approach is not the way things usually work in the Netherlands.
林恩认为这种方法很合理，因为他有阿姆斯特丹警察部队的经验。他帮助清理和改革了该部门。作为一名菜鸟警察，他亲眼目睹了这些问题。他在20世纪80年代红灯区的一个腐败分局开始了职业生涯。他说警察偷窃、贩毒、暴力执法。改变这些意味着严格执行规则，记录坏警察的表现，惩戒他们，解雇他们。林恩说，规则被接受为“正常”大约用了10年时间。但这种对抗性的方式通常不适用于荷兰。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
You know, the Dutch culture is very much everything peace, everything together, no conflict. And with the fire department, the traditional recipe is talking, talking, talking.
你知道，荷兰文化非常追求和平、共处，没有冲突。对于消防部门，传统的处方是谈话、谈话、再谈话。
The Dutch have this term, "polder model." They take pride in it. The idea is to bring everyone together, despite their differences, just like their ancestors came together to build dikes and dams to protect their land from the sea. Historians debate whether that's actually true. But anyway, everyone from Parliament to the local amateur soccer club tries to make decisions this way-- through discussions and consensus.
荷兰人有一个术语，叫“圩田模式”（polder model）。他们对此感到自豪。这个想法是把每个人聚在一起，尽管有分歧，就像他们的祖先为了保护土地免受海洋侵害而齐心协力建造堤坝和水坝一样。历史学家们争论这是否真实。但无论如何，从议会到当地业余足球俱乐部，每个人都试图通过这种方式做出决定——通过讨论和共识。
Leen did dabble with polder model a little in the beginning. He spent his first six months going to fire stations, trying to convince people that diversity would make them a stronger fire department in a city with almost 170 nationalities, and that women bring pragmatism and emotional intelligence to the brigade. But Leen was almost always met with blank stares. Guys told him, women aren't strong enough for this job. One of them said, you just want an excuse to bring in a hundred broads. Again, here's Leen.
林恩在初期确实尝试过一点“圩田模式”。他花了前六个月时间走访消防站，试图说服人们，在一个拥有近170个国籍的城市里，多元化会使他们成为一支更强大的消防队，而且女性会给队伍带来务实精神和情商。但林恩面对的几乎总是空白的凝视。家伙们告诉他：“女性不够强壮，无法胜任这份工作。”其中一个甚至说：“你只是想找个借口带进来一百个荡妇。”再听听林恩怎么说。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Intellectually, it's hard to have these conversations about diversity. And I don't intend to sound crass, and I don't want to be unkind about my people, but some of them are too stupid to keep having this diversity conversation, and convince them that way. And at some point, you just have to say that we're going to stop talking about it. We're just going to do it. And we're going to do it this way.
从智力层面来说，很难进行这些关于多元化的对话。我不想听起来粗鲁，我也不想对我的手下刻薄，但他们中的一些人太蠢了，无法继续进行多元化对话，也无法通过那种方式说服他们。在某个时候，你不得不说我们不再谈论它了。我们直接做。我们将以这种方式去做。
This is an organization. It's not some kind of democratic kumbaya thing where we're all going to talk about it, and then the majority rules. You can take it or leave it.
这是一个组织。这不是某种民主的共融大会，不是我们坐下来谈一谈，然后少数服从多数的地方。要么接受，要么滚蛋。
He was done reasoning with them. He didn't have to, after all. He had the full support of Mayor Eberhard van der Laan, who was wildly popular. The city adored him. He snubbed Vladimir Putin when he was in town because of the Russian leader's anti-LGBT views. The city council backed the mayor, and he backed Leen-- which meant, with the mayor's support, Leen could do whatever he wanted. And he had a big idea for how to get the kind of accountability he wanted in the fire department.
他不再跟他们讲道理了。毕竟他也不需要。他拥有深受民众爱戴的市长埃伯哈德·范德兰（Eberhard van der Laan）的全力支持。这座城市崇拜他。当普京在城里时，因为俄罗斯领导人的反LGBT观点，他曾冷落过普京。市议会支持市长，市长支持林恩——这意味着，有了市长的支持，林恩可以随心所欲。对于如何在消防部门获得他想要的问责制，他有个宏大的想法。
Coming up-- you can discipline people, you can threaten their jobs. But when all else fails, try a talk show. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——你可以惩戒人，可以威胁他们的工作。但当所有方法都失败时，试试脱口秀。还有一分钟，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目将继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "Burn It Down"-- we have two stories of people who think they have no other choice. It is time to burn everything down, make enemies, do what has to be done. We're in the middle of Act One. A policeman burns down a firehouse. Joanna Kakissis, in this act, is reporting on the Amsterdam Fire Department, the resistance to change from inside the department, and, in this half of her story, how the bigger politics of the city start to shift everything.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是《烧掉它》——我们有两个关于人们认为自己别无选择的故事。现在是烧掉一切、制造敌人、做必须做之事的时候了。我们正在第一部分的中间。一名警察烧毁了一个消防站。乔安娜·卡基西斯在这部分报道了阿姆斯特丹消防局、来自部门内部的抵制，以及这部分故事中，这座城市更大的政治局势如何开始改变一切。
Quick program note before we start the second half of this. Joanna discovered, when she started looking into this story, that the fire commander's partner, who is a journalist, is somebody who Joanna has worked with in the past. Joanna has not discussed the content of the story with this journalist. The journalist was not involved in this story in any way. Again, here's Joanna.
在开始下半部分之前有一个快速说明。乔安娜在开始调查这个故事时发现，这位消防指挥官的伴侣——也是一名记者——是乔安娜过去曾合作过的人。乔安娜没有与该记者讨论过这个故事的内容。该记者没有以任何方式参与此故事。再说一遍，下面是乔安娜。
Leen had devised a very unusual plan. But to pull it off, he had to enlist the mayor. He did something that I've rarely seen any public official do-- he took all his criticisms about his own fire department and made them public. And by doing so, he made himself the biggest critic of some of the most beloved figures in Amsterdam.
林恩设计了一个非常不同寻常的计划。但要成功，他必须争取市长的同意。他做了一件我很少见到任何公职人员做过的事——他把他对自己消防部门的所有批评公之于众。通过这样做，他使自己成为了阿姆斯特丹一些最受爱戴人物的头号批评者。
Imagine the head of the police department in New York or Chicago publishing a long list of all the bad stuff their officers had done. It would blow up in their faces. That did not happen to Leen. Here's how he went about it. He started by writing a single letter to the mayor detailing his findings about discrimination and bullying at the fire department.
想象一下纽约或芝加哥的警察局长公布一份长名单，列出他们警官所做的所有坏事。这会让他们身败名裂。林恩身上没发生这种情况。他是这样做的：他首先写了一封信给市长，详细说明了他关于消防部门歧视和霸凌的发现。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
He read the letter. There was a certain surprise, because I think he literally said, I thought there were all kinds of things going on. But it turns out there was even more going on than I thought. But now, I actually have the proof. And now, we're going to work on this together.
“他读了那封信。当时有一种惊讶，因为我想他字面意思是：‘我以为这里发生着各种各样的事。但结果证明这里发生的事情比我想象的还要多。但现在，我确实掌握了证据。现在，我们将一起解决这个问题。’”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
In response, the mayor wrote his own letter blasting the fire department, and sent it with Leen's to the city council, making them public record. Reporters pounced.
作为回应，市长写了一封信痛斥消防部门，并将林恩的信一同发送给市议会，使之成为公开记录。记者们蜂拥而至。
Did you and the mayor-- did the two of you talk about it as a strategy?
你和市长——你们两人谈过这是一种策略吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
It was absolutely my idea. And I knew it was going to end up in the media. I knew this was going to make the papers. So that was something that I thought before-- that if I write this letter, there's going to be a certain amount of pressure that would get the municipal council, and also the public, to see that something needed to be done.
这绝对是我的主意。我知道它最终会出现在媒体上。我知道这会登上报纸。所以我之前就考虑过了——如果我写这封信，会产生一定的压力，促使市议会以及公众意识到必须做点什么。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
This was very, very calculated, even to the point where I did use words that I knew the media would pounce on to get a discussion going.
这是非常、非常精心计算过的，甚至到了我使用一些我知道媒体会争相报道以引发讨论的词汇的程度。
Like what?
比如什么？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Racism, discrimination, bullying, exclusion-- these are terms that I know are going to get people's attention.
种族歧视、排斥、霸凌、排挤——这些是我知道会引起人们关注的术语。
It's really unusual for a public official to do something like this.
公职人员做这种事真的很不寻常。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Yes. It is extremely unusual. But it makes it very effective. And I looked at what former fire commanders did, and I felt that they didn't use the possibilities they had enough. And I consciously decided, I'm going to make war. And that means you have to get your hands dirty, and you have to go public.
是的。这极其不寻常。但这非常有效。我看了前几任消防指挥官的做法，我觉得他们没有充分利用他们所拥有的可能性。我自觉地决定，我要发动战争。这意味着你必须弄脏你的手，你必须公开化。
Do you remember any discussion you had with the mayor, or with anyone else, who was less sure that this was the right way?
你记得你与市长或其他人谈话时，有谁不确定这是正确的方法吗？
Um, ja.
嗯，是的。
Yeah? OK.
是吗？好吧。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
What I noticed with the people around me was mostly fear. And so that was a lot of the people in management here. They supported me, but they were kind of reticent. Because they knew this kind of organization-- if you go looking for a fight, you're going to get a fight.
我从周围人身上感受到的主要是恐惧。所以我这里管理层里的很多人就是这样。他们支持我，但他们有些迟疑。因为他们了解这种组织——如果你去找茬，你就会遇到麻烦。
Did the mayor ever have any reservations about this as a strategy?
市长对这种策略有过任何疑虑吗？
Not one second.
一秒钟都没有。
The details in Leen's report landed on the front page of the main newspaper in Amsterdam. Then, the mayor and Leen went on a media blitz.
林恩报告中的细节登上了阿姆斯特丹主要报纸的头版。然后，市长和林恩展开了媒体闪电战。
[NEWS STATION JINGLE]
[新闻频道片头曲]
Here's Leen on the radio show, flinging open the doors on what really goes on inside a firehouse. The host of the program says to Leen, "So, what you found was a very macho culture. Can you give me some examples of that?"
这是林恩在广播节目中，敞开大门揭露消防站里真正发生的事情。节目主持人对林恩说：“那么，你发现的是一种非常大男子主义的文化。你能给我举几个例子吗？”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Well, if you're sitting at a table, and you're Moroccan, and something comes on TV about Islam, then people start talking about "those cancer Moroccans." And when you're sitting there as a serious professional firefighter, it has an effect on you. And then, of course, you're the exception. Like, hey, we don't mean you. It's those other cancer Moroccans. That's one example.
“嗯，如果你坐在桌子旁，你是摩洛哥人，电视上正在播放关于伊斯兰教的内容，然后人们开始谈论‘那些癌症摩洛哥人’。当你作为一个认真的专业消防员坐在那儿时，这会对你产生影响。然后，当然，你是例外。比如：‘嘿，我们不是指你。是指那些其他癌症摩洛哥人。’这就是一个例子。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
And I've got people telling me I can survive the 24-hour shift. I'll just stay in my room. And then, as a group, you could think, oh, OK. Somebody's spending the whole shift in their room. But you could also think, what's going on here?
还有人告诉我我可以应付24小时轮班制。我只会待在房间里。然后，作为一个群体，你可能会想：‘哦，好吧。有人整班都待在房间里。’但你也可能会想：‘这里到底发生了什么？’”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
And that's really what I want to happen-- that we're able to engage with each other in a healthy way.
而那正是我想要发生的——我们能够以健康的方式互相交流。
People wrote to newspapers saying they were repulsed by the firefighters' behavior. City council members said they were shocked. The mayor told Leen to keep pushing on with his reforms. But inside the firehouses, Leen's tactics did not go over well. His support shrunk. Even people who agreed with his goals, who thought he was fighting the good fight, felt like he was smearing everyone, lumping them together, making them all look bad.
人们写信给报纸，说他们被消防员的行为所厌恶。市议员们表示他们很震惊。市长告诉林恩继续推动改革。但在消防站内部，林恩的策略并没有得到好评。他的支持率缩水了。即使是那些同意他目标的人，认为他在进行正义之战的人，也觉得他在抹黑所有人，把他们混为一谈，让他们看起来都很糟糕。
The way that he did that-- he turned every firefighter against him.
“他那样做——他把每个消防员都推向了自己的对立面。”
This is a longtime firefighter of color in the brigade.
这是一名在队伍中服役多年的有色人种消防员。
Leen and the mayor went about it really radically. They used the newspapers to try to turn public opinion against us. There were very, very hurtful stories in the newspapers that we were racist, that we were sexist-- all kinds of old stories, really, from a decade or more ago were brought back to paint a black picture of us.
“林恩和市长采取的做法真的很激进。他们利用报纸试图让舆论反对我们。报纸上刊登了非常、非常伤人的故事，说我们是种族主义者，说我们是性别歧视者——各种各样的陈年往事，甚至十年前或更久以前的故事被翻出来，把我们描绘得一团黑。”
And of course, The Brotherhood was pissed. It was a public declaration of war. On social media, firefighters called Leen and the mayor "know-it-all political losers" and "vile," "full of lies." They wrote, "Indict this mayor and have him sued for defamation," and, "Thanks, Leen, we're all painted like a bunch of racists."
当然，“兄弟会”被激怒了。这是一次公开宣战。在社交媒体上，消防员称林恩和市长为“自以为是的政治失败者”、“卑鄙”、“充满谎言”。他们写道：“起诉这位市长，以诽谤罪控告他”和“谢谢你，林恩，我们都被描绘成了一群种族主义者。”
Inside the firehouses, the atmosphere changed. Attitudes hardened. Again, here's Ali, the firefighter of color who says his white co-workers called him bin Laden. He said things got worse for anyone who wasn't white.
在消防站内部，气氛变了。态度强硬起来。再次回到阿里，那位有色人种消防员，他说他的白人同事叫他本·拉登。他说，对于任何非白人来说，情况变得更糟了。
Something literally broke. And now, for the first time, you see that people, for instance, won't shake your hand. There's this tradition. After we put out a fire, we always sit on the side. We have a coffee, and all the firemen shake each other's hands. That's really a tradition. And now, for the first time since I've been here, white firefighters are refusing to shake our hands.
有些东西确实破碎了。现在，第一次，你看到人们，例如，拒绝和你握手。这里有个传统。灭火后，我们总是坐在一边。喝杯咖啡，所有的消防员会握手。那真的是一个传统。现在，自从我来到这里以来，这是第一次，白人消防员拒绝握我们的手。
Meanwhile, Leen got more done than ever. He doubled down on recruitment, went to mosques and dinners during Ramadan, tried to convince more people of color and women to join the fire brigade. Slowly, those numbers have increased. He also backed managers who disciplined bad actors. He streamlined work shifts, opened a new firehouse, and improved fire prevention. He made homes safer by sending firefighters door-to-door in the city.
与此同时，林恩完成的事情比以往任何时候都多。他加大了招聘力度，去清真寺和参加斋月晚餐，试图说服更多的有色人种和女性加入消防队。慢慢地，这些数字有所增加。他还支持那些惩戒恶劣分子的经理。他精简了轮班，开设了新的消防站，改善了防火工作。他通过派遣消防员在城市中挨家挨户走访，使家庭变得更安全。
Leen, with the backing of the mayor, was making the kinds of changes he was hired to make, in exactly the way he wanted to make them-- quickly and aggressively. But then, something happened that Leen hadn't accounted for. Six months into his job, Mayor Eberhard van der Laan revealed he was sick-- lung cancer. A half year later, he died. Immediately, the ground started to shift under Leen. When the mayor died, The Brotherhood grew emboldened. Here's Leen.
林恩在市长的支持下，正在进行他被聘请来进行的改革，完全按照他想要的方式——迅速且激进。但后来，发生了一件林恩没考虑到的事情。入职六个月后，市长埃伯哈德·范德兰透露他病了——肺癌。半年后，他去世了。林恩脚下的地面立即开始动摇。市长去世后，“兄弟会”变得胆大起来。听听林恩怎么说。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
People commented that it was great that he died. And there was even somebody, when van der Laan was on his deathbed, who said, "Van der Laan, the cockroach, is slipping away."
人们评论说他死了真是太好了。甚至还有人在范德兰临终时说：“范德兰，那只蟑螂，正在溜走。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
And that was quite shocking-- that somebody is on his deathbed from cancer, and you're rejoicing in that. But for them, it really was one enemy less.
那相当令人震惊——有人因癌症临终，而你却为此欢呼。但对他们来说，确实少了一个敌人。
Soon, a campaign to push Leen out of his job kicked into high gear. Retired firefighters and unions rallied around The Brotherhood, publicly demanding that the city investigate Leen for bad mouthing the fire department in the media. Firefighters did interviews anonymously, denouncing Leen in a conservative newspaper, the biggest paper in the Netherlands. From the moment the mayor announced he was sick, Leen started getting anonymous death threats. One letter said a hitman was being hired. Another targeted his 14-year-old daughter. He was told the threats were coming from inside the fire department.
很快，一场将林恩踢出局的运动如火如荼地展开。退休消防员和工会联合起来支持“兄弟会”，公开要求市政府调查林恩在媒体上诋毁消防部门的行为。消防员匿名接受采访，在荷兰最大的保守派报纸上谴责林恩。从市长宣布他生病的那一刻起，林恩就开始收到匿名死亡威胁。一封信说有人雇了杀手。另一封信盯上了他14岁的女儿。有人告诉他，威胁来自消防部门内部。
In the summer of 2018, Amsterdam got an energetic new mayor, the first woman in the city's history-- Femke Halsema. She was Leen's new boss, and spent many years in parliament as a high-profile lawmaker representing the left-wing Green Party, a champion of women's rights. As a politician, she pushed for tax breaks to address poverty. She also wrote newspaper columns, and made a documentary about Muslim women.
2018年夏天，阿姆斯特丹迎来了一位充满活力的女市长，也是该市历史上第一位女性——费姆克·哈尔瑟马（Femke Halsema）。她是林恩的新老板，曾作为左翼绿党的杰出议员在议会中工作多年，是女性权利的捍卫者。作为政治家，她推动减税以解决贫困问题。她还撰写报纸专栏，并制作了一部关于穆斯林女性的纪录片。
Mayor Halsema condemned the death threats against Leen, and publicly threw her support behind him. But not long after she started, Leen remembers her stopping by for a private meeting. He told her about some of the changes he was trying to make. Her reaction shocked him.
哈尔瑟马市长谴责了针对林恩的死亡威胁，并公开表示支持他。但在她上任不久后，林恩记得她过来进行了一次私人会面。他告诉她他正在尝试进行的一些改变。她的反应让他大吃一惊。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
When we were having this conversation about racism and discrimination, the mayor herself came with the following example. Apparently, she heard from one of the fire stations, or one of the fireman told her, that we have a number of black colleagues working here--
当我们进行关于种族主义和歧视的对话时，市长本人举了以下例子。显然，她从消防站听说的，或者某个消防员告诉她的，我们这里有几名黑人同事——
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
--and there was one that all the other firefighters were calling "Haar," which is a Dutch name. And that wasn't his name.
——有一个，所有其他消防员都叫他“Haar”，这是一个荷兰名字。那不是他的名字。
It was a racist wordplay joke. They looked for reasons to say no to him so they could say, "No, Haar," or in Dutch, "Nee, Haar," which means Negro.
这是一个种族歧视的双关笑话。他们找理由对他说“不”，以便他们可以说“No, Haar”，在荷兰语中，“Nee, Haar”的意思是“黑鬼”。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
The mayor laughed about this and said, this is really funny. I find this extremely hilarious.
市长笑了笑说：“这真的很有趣。我觉得这极其搞笑。”
She seriously laughed?
她认真地笑了？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
She laughed very loudly. And for me, that was really a pivotal moment, in which I realized, I am fighting against all this, and I am dealing with a mayor who thinks this is funny.
她大声笑了出来。对我来说，那是一个关键时刻，我意识到我正在对抗这一切，而我正在应对一个认为这很有趣的市长。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
I told her I was immensely shocked that she had to laugh about these so-called humorous remarks. And I really asked her, what is going wrong here?
我告诉她，她竟然会对这些所谓的幽默言论发笑，这让我感到无比震惊。我真的问她：“这里到底出了什么问题？”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Mayor Halsema, via email, denied Leen's account. She said she's only told the joke in meetings as an example of, quote, "intolerable behavior that's not always recognized as such by firefighters." For Leen, that moment crystallized the world of difference between his old and new boss. After that, he gave up on her.
哈尔瑟马市长通过电子邮件否认了林恩的说法。她说她只是在会议中把这个笑话作为一个例子，引用了“有时未被消防员识别为不可容忍的行为”。对林恩来说，那一刻具体化了他与前任和现任老板之间的天壤之别。在那之后，他不再对她抱有希望。
Mayor Halsema had, like the rest of Amsterdam, seen Leen's fight with the firefighters play out in the media, and she didn't like it. She liked talking up problems and reaching consensus-- the Dutch way. Fire department managers who sat in on meetings with the new mayor and Leen said it was clear right away that they didn't get along-- that sometimes, he was abrasive. Their styles were totally different. They called the mayor "Tai Chi," and Leen "Boxing."
和阿姆斯特丹的其他市民一样，哈尔瑟马市长看过林恩与消防员在媒体上的争斗，她不喜欢。她喜欢谈论问题并达成共识——这是荷兰人的方式。参加新市长与林恩会议的消防部门经理表示，很明显他们合不来——有时他很生硬。他们的风格截然不同。他们称市长为“太极”，称林恩为“拳击”。
The mayor ordered her own investigation into the fire department. The new investigation acknowledged there were problems, but it concluded that overall, the fire department was, quote, "at its core not a racist or sexist organization," and it called on Leen to take a different approach, and build trust with firefighters. A city hall reporter told me this report basically threw Leen under the bus. When it came out at the end of 2018, Leen had been on the job for about two and a half years. I spoke to him around this time. He seemed unfazed by the report. He was still going about the business of reforming the fire department, and airing its dirty laundry, like this problem firefighter.
市长下令对自己消防部门进行调查。新的调查承认存在问题，但结论是总体而言，消防部门“从本质上讲并非种族主义或性别歧视组织”，并呼吁林恩采取不同方法，与消防员建立信任。一位市政厅记者告诉我，这份报告基本上把林恩卖了。2018年底报告发布时，林恩已经在职约两年半了。我在这个时候采访了他。他看起来并没有受到报告的影响。他仍然在进行改革消防部门的工作，并揭露它的丑事，比如这个有问题的消防员。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
He's not fired yet, but I'm going to fire him. So here's the situation. There was a group of firefighters in a supermarket, because they were doing shopping for their firehouse. They were all in their uniforms, standing at the register. And at the register, there was also an elderly lady on a mobility scooter.
“他还没被解雇，但我打算解雇他。情况是这样的：有一群消防员在超市里，因为他们正在为消防站购物。他们都穿着制服，站在收银台前。在收银台，还有一位坐着残疾车的老太太。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
She's trying to pay for her groceries, and 150 euros falls out of her pocket. And one of the firemen sees that-- that she drops this money-- and puts it into his sock, and walks out with it. Well, some time passes, and the elderly lady goes home, and she realizes her money's gone.
她正试图为她的杂货付款，150欧元从她口袋里掉了出来。其中一个消防员看到了——他看到她掉了钱——然后把它放进自己的袜子里，带着钱走了。嗯，过了一段时间，老太太回家后意识到钱不见了。
The woman checked back with the store about her missing cash, and security camera showed one of Leen's men putting her money in a sock. Taking an old lady's money while you're wearing your firefighter's uniform-- of course, that did not fly with Leen. The police got involved. It was embarrassing and outrageous.
老太太回商店查询她丢失的现金，安全摄像头显示林恩的一名手下把她的钱放进了袜子里。穿着消防员制服偷老太太的钱——当然，这在林恩那里行不通。警察介入了。这既令人尴尬又令人愤怒。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
But the reaction isn't like, oh my god, I can't believe he stole that money.
但反应并不是说：“噢，天哪，我不相信他偷了那笔钱。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Instead, the reaction is that it's ridiculous that I'm going to fire him, because he returned the money to the police.
相反，反应是：我要解雇他这件事很荒谬，因为他已经把钱还给警察了。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
This spring, a group of firefighters showed up at a city council meeting to air their grievances against Leen. Also, they're retired firefighters. A firefighter named Mike Snijder stood at a podium. He's clean cut, has a baby face. He read a statement.
今年春天，一群消防员出现在市议会会议上，表达他们对林恩的不满。此外，还有退休消防员。一名叫迈克·斯奈德（Mike Snijder）的消防员站在讲台上。他长相清秀，看起来像个娃娃脸。他宣读了一份声明。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Enough is enough. Even though I'm taking a huge risk by speaking here today, I'm willing to take that risk for my colleagues who are having complete mental breakdowns. Our leaders have chosen to bad mouth us in the media, and that makes us feel unsafe, both in public and at the fire stations, too, where we're constantly walking on eggshells. The fire department leadership has proven, time and again, that they aren't interested in building trust. There will always be fear and distrust. This is a broken marriage that can't be fixed.
“够了就是够了。尽管今天在这里发言我要冒巨大的风险，但我愿意为那些正经历彻底心理崩溃的同事承担这个风险。我们的领导选择在媒体上诋毁我们，这让我们在公共场合和消防站都感到不安全，在那里我们不得不时刻如履薄冰。消防部门的领导一次又一次地证明，他们对建立信任不感兴趣。恐惧和不信任将永远存在。这是一段无法修复的破碎婚姻。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Dank.
谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
He said Leen made it so firefighters couldn't do their jobs properly, and that it was threatening the safety of everyone in Amsterdam. A city council person asked him to say more.
他说林恩使消防员无法正常工作，这威胁到了阿姆斯特丹所有人的安全。一名市议员要求他多说一些。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
If we're constantly having to look around to make sure that the leadership isn't looking over our shoulders, then we can't do our job.
如果我们不得不时刻环顾四周，确保领导没有盯着我们的肩膀，那我们就无法完成工作。
City council is a political position. You get voted in. And, like the fire department, it's mostly white. Under the old mayor, the council was in full support of Leen. When he first exposed the racism and sexism in the department two years before this, they'd been on his side.
市议会是一个政治职位。你是被投票选出来的。而且，像消防部门一样，它主要是白人。在前市长领导下，议会全力支持林恩。两年前他首次揭露部门内的种族主义和性别歧视时，他们还站在他这一边。
But now, that was old news. The public had moved on. Amsterdam's a progressive city, but on race, it has blind spots. During the holidays, some people still wear blackface when they dress up as St. Nick's helpers. And the public shock over the racism and sexism in the department didn't last. What was more shocking was the way Leen was speaking out. The city council was tired of Leen waging this loud, messy fight. And at this meeting, they were sympathetic to Leen's critics.
但现在，那已是旧闻。公众已经往前看了。阿姆斯特丹是一个进步城市，但在种族问题上，它有盲点。在节日期间，有些人装扮成圣尼古拉斯的帮手时仍然会涂黑脸。而公众对部门内种族主义和性别歧视的震惊并没有持续多久。更令人震惊的是林恩说话的方式。市议会厌倦了林恩进行这种大声、杂乱的斗争。在这次会议上，他们同情林恩的批评者。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Here's one city councilwoman saying, "I know you can't talk to the press, but you can come to me." She also said, "I think it's very brave of you to be here today."
这是一位市议员说的：“我知道你不能对媒体说，但你可以来找我。”她还说：“我认为你今天能站在这里非常勇敢。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Retired firefighters jumped up from their chairs, gave a standing ovation.
退休消防员从椅子上跳起来，起立鼓掌。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Leen is there, annoyed.
林恩在那里，很恼火。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
He literally said, I can't do my job because I feel that the boss is looking over my shoulder. And like, really? You can't do your job when somebody is looking at what you're doing?
“他字面意思是：‘我无法完成我的工作，因为我觉得老板在盯着我的肩膀。’而这，真的吗？当有人在看你在做什么时，你就无法完成工作了？”
Leen says cops use the same arguments to fight any change.
林恩说警察也用同样的论点来反抗任何改变。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
How do you alarm public opinion? By suggesting that what we're doing is making the public unsafe.
你怎么惊动舆论？通过暗示我们的所作所为正在让公众处于不安全之中。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
If they can't do their job because they're afraid, then that's unsafe for the public.
如果他们因为害怕而无法完成工作，那对公众来说就是不安全的。
Mayor Halsema did not feel the same way. After the meeting, she gave this interview to local news.
哈尔瑟马市长并不这么认为。会后，她接受了当地新闻的采访。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
She says, "Of course it's very worrying. If they don't have a good work environment, that could indirectly affect their ability to do their jobs well."
她说：“这当然非常令人担忧。如果他们没有良好的工作环境，那可能会间接影响他们出色完成工作的能力。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
And, "We do have to take these firefighters' concerns seriously." After that city council meeting, Leen knew he was running out of options. City council had lost faith in him, the mayor was not on his side, and 400 firefighters-- more than half the brigade-- signed a petition saying they didn't trust him to run the department.
“我们必须认真对待这些消防员的关切。”那次市议会会议后，林恩知道他快没选择了。市议会对他失去了信心，市长不支持他，400名消防员——超过一半的队伍——签署了一份请愿书，表示不信任他管理该部门。
Inside the fire department, Leen's supporters started to hear rumors. I caught up with some of them in May, not long after the city council meeting.
在消防部门内部，林恩的支持者开始听到传言。我在5月份，那次市议会会议后不久，赶上了他们中的一些人。
Do you think Commander Schaap is about to get fired?
你认为沙普指挥官要被解雇了吗？
I hope it's not fast. I hope he doesn't leave.
我希望没那么快。我希望他不要离开。
Again here's, Ali.
再次回到阿里。
What would that mean for you, personally, if he was?
如果他离开了，这对你个人意味着什么？
I'd be very disappointed. What he did is give minorities a platform where they could speak out. And that wasn't there before him. Now, we're in direct contact with the upper echelons of management. We can immediately reach them, ask for help-- we get a lot of support. And that definitely makes a difference.
我会非常失望。他所做的是为少数群体提供了一个可以发声的平台。在他之前并没有这个平台。现在，我们与管理层高层保持直接联系。我们可以立即联系他们，寻求帮助——我们得到了很多支持。这绝对带来了改变。
Leen had been there almost three years, and Ali, and a couple of female managers, told me they were finally starting to see change. Firefighters were thinking twice before making racist and sexist comments.
林恩在那里工作了近三年，阿里和几位女性经理告诉我，他们终于开始看到变化。消防员在发表种族主义和性别歧视言论之前会三思而后行。
Everybody's more careful now. People are really correcting each other. Still, things happen, and people make jokes like that. But someone will say, hey, watch out. It's something you could have said before in the old days. Nowadays, you can't do this anymore. Now, all the improvements we've seen over the past few years-- if he leaves, you can throw all that in the Amstel River. It's going to be back to square one. These angry white men have always been dominant. They always decided what went down.
每个人现在都更谨慎了。人们确实在互相纠正。事情依然会发生，人们依然会讲那样的笑话。但会有人说：“嘿，注意点。”这是以前的日子里你本来可以随便说的话。如今，你不能再这样做了。现在，我们过去几年看到的所有进步——如果他离开了，你可以把所有这些扔进阿姆斯特尔河里。一切都会回到原点。这些愤怒的白人男性一直占据主导地位。他们总是决定事情的走向。
Does the city-- does the mayor understand that this is now the situation?
市政府——市长理解现在的情况吗？
Well, I don't know about the mayor. She's new. But I hope she won't fire him. If she does fire him, just shake hands on it with us and say, OK, we don't want people of color in the fire brigade. That would be a fair way to go about it. Just say, OK. Quit it. We only want white people. Because that's the message they would give.
嗯，我不了解市长。她是新人。但我希望她不要解雇他。如果她解雇他，就跟我们握手言和，直接说：“好吧，我们不想要有色人种进消防队。”那将是一种公平的方式。就说：“好吧。算了吧。我们只想要白人。”因为那就是他们会给出的信号。
That's what it'd signal to you-- is she saying, I don't need any more people like you, I don't need any more minorities?
这对你意味着什么——她是想说，“我不再需要像你这样的人，我不再需要少数群体了”？
Not just, "I don't need any more people"-- "I don't need people like you anymore." This culture forms over a hundred years, and it's really hard to try to get a foot in the door while people just want their old fire brigade back. And they will resist any change. That's reality.
不仅仅是“我不再需要更多人”——“我不再需要像你这样的人了。”这种文化经过一百年的形成，而在人们只想找回他们旧的消防队时，试图挤进去真的很难。而且他们会抵抗任何改变。这就是现实。
I asked Leen to give me a gut check.
我请林恩做一个直觉判断。
Do you feel like your days are numbered?
你觉得你的日子不多了吗？
[SIGH] Uh.
[叹气] 嗯。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Big sigh.
深深的叹息。
Yeah.
是的。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
He wants to talk-- I think we should talk about that maybe at a different moment.
他想谈谈——我想也许我们在另一个时刻谈谈这个。
It's not something that you really want to talk about right now?
这不是你现在真正想谈的事？
No, no.
不，不。
Have you made a pitch to the mayor about why you should stay?
你向市长争取过为什么你应该留下吗？
Ja.
是的。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
I told her that the phase we're in now-- it takes about six years to break the habits. And so only after six years old should you start thinking about unifying things. And I think now, the municipal organization is all about trying to find unification. But I think that's too soon. And so I told her, you should just leave me here for another couple of years to do the breaking bit.
“我告诉她，我们现在处于这个阶段——打破习惯大约需要六年。所以只有在六年之后，你才应该开始考虑统一的事情。而我认为现在，市政组织的一切都是为了试图寻找统一。但我认为那还太早。所以我告诉她，你应该把我留在这里再待几年，做那个‘打破’的部分。”
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
What did the mayor say?
市长说了什么？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
She nodded.
她点了点头。
The mayor declined many requests for an interview. I wondered if Leen was regretting his management style, if he was thinking he should have been more polder model-- more diplomatic.
市长拒绝了多次采访请求。我好奇林恩是否后悔他的管理风格，是否在想他应该更“圩田模式”——更外交一些。
Do you feel like there's something about the way you do things that perhaps contributed? So this is something that you may see in retrospect, like, I should have done this differently, or I should have approached this differently. I'm just curious.
你觉得你做事的方式是否有某种程度的贡献？所以这可能是你回顾时看到的，比如“我应该以不同方式做这件事，或者我应该以不同方式对待这事”。我只是好奇。
Ja.
是的。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
Sometimes I think maybe, in retrospect, I wanted results too fast.
有时我想也许，回顾过去，我想要的成果太快了。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
But a real cultural change really can't be forced, or sped up. So instead of creating more support, you get more resistance because the organization isn't ready to change.
但真正的文化改变真的无法强迫，也无法加速。所以与其创造更多支持，你反而会得到更多抵抗，因为组织还没有准备好改变。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
And so I was very black and white. And I don't really regret it. But maybe, I think now, with more nuance, I would have opened it more to conversation instead of just resistance.
所以我非常非黑即白。我不后悔。但也许，我想现在，如果多一点细微差别，我会更多地把它推向对话，而不是仅仅是抵抗。
Do you think the conversation would have helped?
你认为对话会有帮助吗？
No.
不会。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
That's the dilemma.
这就是困境。
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
But honesty begs me to say that I also really didn't try. I just went down and laid down the law. And maybe, if I tried, then it would have been slightly different. But the question really is, how long do you want it to take? Do you accept this kind of behavior to continue for another 20 years? And I'm trying to change it sooner rather than later.
但诚实要求我承认，我也确实没有尝试。我只是走下去，制定了规则。也许，如果我尝试了，那会稍微不同。但真正的问题是，你希望它持续多久？你接受这种行为再持续20年吗？我正试图尽早改变它。
So Leen, I'm starting to think-- and maybe this is me just being paranoid-- but I'm starting to think that you're telling me that your days are numbered. Is that what you're telling me right now?
所以林恩，我开始觉得——也许只是我多疑——但我开始觉得你是在告诉我，你的日子不多了。这就是你现在想告诉我的吗？
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
[荷兰语发言]
I am not allowed to speak about this.
我不被允许谈论这件事。
Leen's last day as commander of the Amsterdam Fire Department is October 1. Mayor Halsema issued a press release recently announcing his departure, and made it clear that she had forced him out. She says combating discrimination is still a top priority.
林恩作为阿姆斯特丹消防局局长的最后一天是10月1日。哈尔瑟马市长最近发布了一份新闻稿，宣布了他的离职，并明确表示是她把他赶走的。她说打击歧视仍然是首要任务。
When the news came out, firefighters at one station celebrated with cake. A photo circulated on social media of firefighters in front of a fire truck wearing party hats. The Brotherhood had won. One guy tweeted, "Bye bye, Kim Jung Schaap." The day Leen's departure was announced, a firefighter parked a camper van at a station.
消息传出后，一个站点的消防员用蛋糕庆祝。一张消防员在消防车前戴着派对帽的照片在社交媒体上流传。“兄弟会”赢了。有人推文写道：“拜拜，金正沙普（Kim Jung Schaap）。”林恩离职宣布的当天，一名消防员把一辆房车停在了一个站点。
Joanna Kakissis. She's normally a reporter for NPR'S Daily News programs.
乔安娜·卡基西斯。她通常是NPR每日新闻节目的记者。
[MUSIC - "TIME FOR YOU TO GO" BY THE THREE TO GET]
[音乐 - The Three To Get的《Time for You to Go》]
Act Two. Mom? Hey, mom? Mom? Mom! Hey, Mom! Mom! Mom! So we have time on the show today for just one more quick story about somebody deciding that the only way forward is to rip something down and rebuild from the ground up. Elna Baker, tell us what happened.
第二部分。妈妈？嘿，妈妈？妈妈？妈妈！嘿，妈妈！妈妈！妈妈！所以我们今天节目里还有时间，讲最后一个简短的故事，关于有人决定前进的唯一方法就是拆掉某些东西，并从头开始重建。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker），告诉我们发生了什么。
Here's a typical day from when Katie Dyer was 15, growing up outside Detroit. She gets home from school--
这是凯蒂·戴尔（Katie Dyer）15岁时在底特律郊外成长过程中典型的一天。她放学回家——
And our chore list was posted on the banister. And I was really frustrated, because it was longer than normal, and there were chickens from where the sliding glass door had been left open.
我们的家务清单贴在扶手上。我非常沮丧，因为它比平时更长，而且因为滑动玻璃门开着，还有鸡进来了。
This happened all the time. Her mom loved chickens, and they got in the house. Here a chick, there a chick, everywhere a-- you know.
这经常发生。她妈妈喜欢鸡，它们进了屋子。这儿一只小鸡，那儿一只小鸡，到处都是——你知道的。
There were chickens perched on the couch. There were chickens on the kitchen counter, and on the dining room table. I mean, there were just chickens everywhere. And I looked up the stairs, and she was sitting at the computer. And I was just-- in that moment, I was very frustrated. Because now, I've got to herd the chickens outside, complete all these chores-- so I was just very irritated. And at some point, rather than going straight into my chores, I sat down to journal.
沙发上栖息着鸡。厨房台面上和餐桌上有鸡。我的意思是，到处都是鸡。我抬头看楼上，她正坐在电脑前。那一刻，我非常沮丧。因为现在，我得把鸡赶到外面，完成所有这些家务——所以我非常恼火。在某个时刻，我没有直接去干家务，而是坐下来写日记。
Will you read me what you wrote?
你能读读你写了什么吗？
Yeah. So in this entry, it says, "My mom never does anything but sit at the computer and play the stupid Sims online anymore."
是的。所以在这一条里，它写着：“我妈妈现在除了坐在电脑前玩那个愚蠢的《模拟人生》（Sims）之外，什么都不做了。”
That's what her mom was doing when she came home from school-- playing The Sims. You know, the video game where you get a simulated family and a simulated house to live a simulated life.
这就是她放学回家时她妈妈正在做的事——玩《模拟人生》。你知道的，那个电子游戏，你可以拥有一个模拟家庭和一个模拟房子来过一种模拟生活。
Today, she made me do all the real chores after school because she was busy doing fake ones on The Sims. She brought home three fancy chickens today. Oh, great-- more fucking birds. OK. Gotta go. Bye.
“今天，她让我放学后做所有的真正家务，因为她忙着在《模拟人生》里做假家务。她今天带回了三只漂亮的鸡。哦，太棒了——更多的鸟。好吧。得走了。拜拜。”
Katie says her mom moved out of her bedroom and set up a futon in the computer room to sleep next to the game. She'd play, crash on the futon, play more. Katie craved her attention.
凯蒂说她妈妈搬出了卧室，在电脑房里搭了一张折叠床，睡在游戏机旁边。她玩游戏，在折叠床上崩溃睡觉，然后再玩。凯蒂渴望得到她的关注。
I remember, I used to just sometimes go up to her little den area, where her computer was set. And sometimes, doing things just to intentionally annoy her-- but in a funny way. Like, I would take her headphones off, and I would just come up to her, and sort of zerbert her neck-- like, raspberry her neck. Or, like-- what can I do to get your attention?
我记得，我过去有时会走到她的小窝区，就是她放电脑的地方。有时，做些事情只是为了故意惹她生气——但以一种有趣的方式。比如，我会摘下她的耳机，我只会走到她身边，然后在她脖子上发出“噗噗”声——就像，在她脖子上发出覆盆子声。或者，比如——我能做什么来吸引你的注意力？
Katie began to feel invisible.
凯蒂开始觉得自己隐形了。
Like, I was just standing there, waving my arms over my head-- which is hilarious, because that's something the Sims would literally do. When they wanted your attention, they'd put their arms over their head, and wave them, and shout at you in whatever Sim language they speak.
就像，我就站在那儿，在头顶挥舞着手臂——这很滑稽，因为那是《模拟人生》里的模拟人真的会做的事。当他们想要你的注意力时，他们会把手臂放在头上，挥舞它们，并用他们所说的任何模拟人语言对你大喊大叫。
Sometimes, Katie would catch glimpses of the world her mom was building. In The Sims, her mother played the guitar and piano, had dinner parties. She also had a Sims family named after her real husband and kids. Her sister and father looked like their Sims-- but not Katie. In real life, Katie dyed her hair and dressed edgy.
有时，凯蒂会瞥见她妈妈正在建造的世界。在《模拟人生》中，她妈妈弹吉他和钢琴，举办晚宴。她还有一个以她真实的丈夫和孩子命名的模拟家庭。她的姐妹和父亲看起来像他们的模拟人——但凯蒂不像。现实生活中，凯蒂染了头发，穿着前卫。
But I remember-- the Sim that she had named after me had this stupid, almost bowl-cut-looking brown hair, and always wore these pencil skirts and button-ups. And I remember thinking, like, that's not me at all. Is that who you wish I was?
但我记得——她以我的名字命名的那个模拟人留着那种愚蠢的、看起来像碗盖头的棕色头发，而且总是穿着铅笔裙和扣子衬衫。我记得当时在想：“那根本不是我。那是你希望我成为的样子吗？”
She tried everything she could think of to coax her mom off the Sims. She tried to reason with her, joke with her, bargain with her. Finally, Katie reached a breaking point. One night, she sat down at the computer and opened her mom's Sims world.
她尝试了所有能想到的方法来劝她妈妈离开《模拟人生》。她试着跟她讲道理、开玩笑、讨价还价。最后，凯蒂达到了崩溃点。一天晚上，她坐在电脑前，打开了她妈妈的《模拟人生》世界。
With her literally sleeping on the futon, just five feet away from me, was like-- well, I'm doing this. The first thing I did was-- so there was a cheat code. I think it's a semicolon and an exclamation point, over and over. You put it in, and you can get, like-- it was a lot of money. I got enough money that I could buy multiple stoves, mostly.
“她当时真的睡在离我只有五英尺远的折叠床上，就像是——好吧，我做了。我做的第一件事是——有一个作弊码。我想是一个分号和一个感叹号，一遍又一遍。你输入它，你就可以得到，比如——那有很多钱。我得到了足够的钱，我可以买多个炉子，大部分是。”
Another thing that I did, I remember, is you could buy-- I think it was like-- you know those oversized teddy bears people give? You could buy these giant oversized bears, and put them near the fireplace, and stuff like that. And so I removed the fire extinguishers, and the smoke detectors, and stuff. And I remember walking the Sim she had named after me out to the yard, and deleting the door behind me that went out to the front yard, and just waiting.
“我做的另一件事，我记得，你可以买——我想是——你知道人们送的那种超大泰迪熊吗？你可以买这些巨大的超大熊，把它们放在壁炉附近之类的。所以我移除了灭火器，还有烟雾探测器之类的东西。我还记得把她以我名字命名的模拟人走到院子里，删除了通往前院的门，然后等着。”
Her dad and sister Sim go to the stoves and start cooking. Soon, a kitchen and a living room fire break out. The sparks hit the teddy bears-- game on.
她父亲和姐妹模拟人走到炉子前开始做饭。很快，厨房和客厅爆发了大火。火花击中了泰迪熊——游戏开始了。
And the Sims are just running around, screaming with their hands in the air. And like--
而模拟人们只是在四处奔跑，双手举在空中尖叫。就像——
And they really scream, right?
他们真的会尖叫，对吧？
Yes. They scream in whatever that weird Sim language is.
是的。他们用那种奇怪的模拟人语言尖叫。
Can you do it?
你能做一下吗？
[SCREAMING IN SIMLISH] It's just like that. It's just gibberish. And I'm laughing so hard. Like, I remember at some point thinking, I'm going to pee my pants. And I'm trying so hard to not laugh out loud, because she's sleeping right behind me.
[尖叫声] 就像那样。那只是胡言乱语。我笑得太厉害了。我记得在某个时刻想：我快要尿裤子了。我拼命忍住不大笑，因为她就睡在我后面。
There were firemen, but they'd only come if you told your Sim to call them.
有消防员，但只有你告诉你的模拟人叫他们，他们才会来。
I burned her Sim house and family alive.
我把她的模拟房子和家人活活烧死了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Eventually, the fire stops. The Katie character stands in the yard. Her mom, father, and sister are dead. When a Sim dies, this little urn appears in its place.
最终，火熄灭了。凯蒂的角色站在院子里。她妈妈、父亲和姐妹都死了。当一个模拟人死时，这个小骨灰盒会出现在它的位置。
I went back in the house. And you could pick up the little urns. And I picked up the little urns, and just placed them near each other, and knew, well, I'm going to be in a lot of trouble tomorrow.
我回到屋子里。你可以捡起那些小骨灰盒。我捡起那些小骨灰盒，只是把它们放在一起，并且知道，好吧，明天我会有大麻烦了。
Because Katie was the only Sim left, it was going to be pretty clear who'd done all this.
因为凯蒂是唯一剩下的模拟人，谁做了这一切会非常明显。
I got up the next morning to leave for school. And I remember, as I was leaving, she was just sort of starting to get logged into her game and stuff. When I got home, she yelled at me to come up the stairs. I came up the stairs, and she paused her Sim game that she had been rebuilding to turn around and yell at me. And she was like, you owe me an apology. That was weeks of my life. And it still felt like a small victory, I guess, because it was one of the first times in a while that she had to step away from that life to engage her real life.
第二天早上我起床去学校。我记得，我离开时，她才刚开始登录她的游戏之类的。我回家时，她冲我大喊大叫让我上楼。我上楼后，她暂停了她一直在重建的模拟游戏，转过身来对我大喊大叫。她说：“你欠我一个道歉。那是我的几周生命。”这仍然感觉像是一场小小的胜利，我想，因为它是我在一段时间内第一次让她不得不离开那个生活，去参与她的现实生活。
She wrote in her journal, "Grounded. Figures. But it was funny. I have to do all the housework now so she can rebuild. I do all of it anyway, so whatever. Dad thinks I'll go to jail someday. At least in jail, they don't make you get up at 6:00 AM to feed chickens."
她在日记中写道：“禁足。没意外。但那很有趣。我必须做所有的家务，这样她才能重建。反正我一直在做，所以无所谓。爸爸觉得我有一天会坐牢。至少在监狱里，他们不会让你早上6点起床去喂鸡。”
[FIRE NOISES AND SCREAMING]
[火声和尖叫声]
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Katie Dyer has done no jail time, and she's a bus driver and mom in Knoxville. A version of her story originally appeared on Mortified. You can get their podcast wherever you get your podcasts, or at getmortified.com.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制片人之一。凯蒂·戴尔没有坐过牢，她是诺克斯维尔的一名公交车司机和妈妈。她的故事版本最初出现在《Mortified》节目中。你可以在你获得播客的任何地方，或在getmortified.com上获取他们的播客。
[MUSIC - "REBEL GIRL BY BIKINI KILL]
[音乐 - Bikini Kill的《Rebel Girl》]
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek, with help from Nadia Reiman. People who put the show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhop, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Julie Snyder, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由米基·米克制作，纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）提供帮助。今天制作节目的其他人包括比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、杰西卡·卢森霍普（Jessica Lussenhop）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。
Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Our interpreters for today's show-- Stephanie van den Berg, Joost van Egmond, and Helena de Groot. The voice actors you heard-- Michiel Bakker, Mike Lebanon, and Jara Lucieer. I'm going to just say-- these things are so hard to pronounce. For the special thanks, I'm going to hand it over to our interpreter, Helena de Groot.
我们的总编辑是吴黛安（Diane Wu）。我们的执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们今天节目的译员——斯蒂芬妮·范登伯格（Stephanie van den Berg）、朱斯特·范埃格蒙德（Joost van Egmond）和海伦娜·德·格鲁特（Helena de Groot）。你听到的配音演员——米歇尔·巴克（Michiel Bakker）、迈克·黎巴嫩（Mike Lebanon）和贾拉·卢西尔（Jara Lucieer）。我只想说——这些名字真的很难发音。对于特别鸣谢，我将交给我们的译员，海伦娜·德·格鲁特。
Special thanks today to Hagar Jobse, Hannah van der Wurff, Aviva de Kornfeld, Joost Kampen, Elly Kloosterman, Kemal Rijken, Anke Truijen, Hassan Bahara, Ruben Koops, Hans van Velden, Dimitris Angelidis, Toby Sterling, Bo Tarenskeen, and Christopher Miller.
今天特别鸣谢哈加尔·乔布斯（Hagar Jobse）、汉娜·范德沃夫（Hannah van der Wurff）、阿维娃·德·科恩费尔德（Aviva de Kornfeld）、朱斯特·坎彭（Joost Kampen）、埃莉·克洛斯特曼（Elly Kloosterman）、凯末尔·里肯（Kemal Rijken）、安克·特鲁恩（Anke Truijen）、哈桑·巴哈拉（Hassan Bahara）、鲁本·库普斯（Ruben Koops）、汉斯·范·维尔登（Hans van Velden）、迪米特里斯·安杰利迪斯（Dimitris Angelidis）、托比·斯特林（Toby Sterling）、博·塔伦斯金（Bo Tarenskeen）和克里斯托弗·米勒（Christopher Miller）。
Thank you, Helena. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's like a marriage expert-- everyone on staff goes to him for advice all the time.
谢谢你，海伦娜。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他就像一位婚姻专家——员工们总是向他寻求建议。
I'm 29 years with my wife. If I focus on all the bad things that I said about her, then we would never get married.
“我和我妻子在一起29年了。如果我盯着那期间我说过的所有坏话看，那我们根本就不会结婚。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "REBEL GIRL BY BIKINI KILL]
[音乐 - Bikini Kill的《Rebel Girl》]